we're from with griffin
all right y'all
let's do it
wait a minute something happened there
you see that
every time you think you got it right
you know that's what happens when you do
[ __ ] live
wait what's going on with the
my music's not coming on man
just stay with me y'all stay with me
[Laughter]
why is it just working
oh man we got to do the theme song right
i don't know what is happening here
let me see hold up
this will be all part of the that i'll
take off the audio version but
we're doing it live so this is what
happens when you this is what happens
when you when you when you do a live
podcast john and stuff happens
i don't know what i don't know what is
going on
but the
my cord is not
picking up the damn
the music
i don't know what's going on
i don't know what's going on
what
wait this let's see does the mic work
hello
all right this works
oh there it is yeah
okay we got it back
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay today i'm gonna talk about my trip
to canada
of course we gotta go over the nfl
playoff weekend the most i mean
spectacular weekend of football i've
ever seen in my life
two shows i'm gonna review
as we see it with my buddy rick glassman
and ozark season four
[Music]
it was spectacular
so stay tuned for that thanks for being
here once again
i don't know what happened there that
was that was crazy
that was bananas but it is what it is
you know
so
anyways welcome to roofing with griffin
y'all
welcome to riffin with griffin um
let's see
what's going on this week so
as always thanks for listening and
watching the podcast
once again i was traveling so it was
like there was no there was no like
recording it ahead of time and it just
to me is just easier for me just to go
live you know what i mean i like having
the interaction with the fans in the
youtube chat
and uh you know
i just like doing it like this sometimes
uh but i do have guests planned and
we're gonna be doing that and um
as always every day make sure you uh
check me out on eric griffin gaming on
twitch
uh check me out on king and the sting
and also gender gen yeah that is still a
thing
um
let's see uh what am i talking about so
and welcome
so first we just starting off with like
how was my weekend and uh you know i
just want to talk about traveling so
this uh picture right here is uh
the my view from my second hotel to the
hotel that i initially was in
man my cough is still here i still get
this nasal drip i actually think of my
allergies or some of my allergies right
now i noticed when i came home i think
there's something in my i gotta like
vacuum and you know take care of this
office because something's messing with
my throat but anyways
so welcome to the show so this weekend i
went to canada
and
man i just
want a [ __ ] about some stuff because
this is what i do this is my brand if
you don't like it leave my podcast you
know you don't even need to comment like
why comment when this is what i do you
know you know you know me while you if
you've been watching my podcast for all
this time now 169 episodes and you're
still going god you complain about stuff
if you're still saying that like
i got
eat a dick okay that's just the best way
i could say it okay that's
you're
at this point you're the fool if you're
still complaining about me complaining
like that don't even make any sense
you know what i mean but anyways
all right so
first of all to go to canada
is a nightmare all right just
the fact that you have to
all right so first you gotta be
vaccinated okay
and now
listen i got no problem with that i i
get i get it all right you wanna you
have to be vaccinated all right all
right so you gotta be vaccinated so it's
like whatever with that okay
let me fix my green screen
all right so you gotta be vaccinated
fine
so on top of that you gotta get
a covet test
and not just a regular cova test the
country of canada says to come into our
country you got to get this
pcr test
i don't know what the difference is i
need somebody medical to explain to me
why
that test and this other test is so
different
so you got to get it at a certain time
before you travel
so i came in i came home from another
trip on a sunday night so then you have
i wake up
excuse me monday so i got monday and i'm
leaving again wednesday so i can't get a
70 72 hour one or 48 hour one now i
gotta pay a hundred and eighty five
dollars to get this test
a hundred and eighty five dollars all
right
vaccinate it get the test okay so then i
gotta do that so then now when you're in
canada to leave canada to fly you have
to get
another test but it's not as strict this
one seems to be like the same test you
could just buy over the counter because
you can get the results in 20 30 minutes
but they still charging 50 60 for that
depending on where you go all right so
yes it's almost 250 dollars extra for me
to for to travel to and from canada
and i'm like what
it's a racket man
like
like like
why is that the cost
you know it's like you want me to fly
your airline take care of it
like to me it feels like the airline
should be like all right we want to make
sure we want to make sure people are
safe so we're going to have a little
area that you have to come to uh you
know just like they have tsa just that
they have security area uh you know you
have to get to the airport 30 minutes
even 30 minutes even more and then okay
here's we're going to do the test are
you clear boom now you can get on the
plane
but they making us pay like
it seems like another way for people to
make money man
now just because i feel this way doesn't
mean i don't care about health and
safety that's the thing i take offense
to because i was i put some a post up on
instagram and i got a lot of idiots like
hitting me up like oh
oh is it an inconvenience to care about
people's health and safety this has
nothing to do with people's health and
safety i can two things can be true
i can care about health and safety and i
can also think that this is nonsense uh
having to spend all this money on a test
that
that's probably a fraction of that cost
to get done you know if they really if
they how come we don't question if they
care about health and safety how can we
not going hey airlines and and hey uh
you know
the government that makes these rules do
you care about health and safety too
then why aren't you doing something
about this price gouging for these
stupid um
just stupid
you know
testing procedures that they have going
on
you know so i got a lot of dumb ass
comments man
one dumb man one dumb comment i got was
you know this guy's trying to be like
like trying to be facetious right so
he's all like oh yeah
even though you wear a seat belt you
still get into an accident
so i had to hit him back and was like yo
that ain't the right analogy
the proper analogy is
just because you were you wore a seat
belt and you still got injured
that's the proper analogy because that's
true like being vaccinated doesn't mean
you're not going to get covet
but
getting vaccinated
you have a smaller
your percentage goes down of like being
hospitalized death it affecting you in
the same way that a seatbelt helps you
in the car but it don't you can still
die you can still get injured but your
percentage goes up with those things not
to happen that's why they have a seat
belt mandate right
but it's not the same thing
every time people bring that up i go
that's not the same thing you know why
it's not the same thing
because if every time i put on my
seatbelt i had to pay 25 let's say that
would be the same thing then we'd all be
bitching about [ __ ] wouldn't we what if
every time you put on your seatbelt
a government mandated thing the
government says you have to wear a seat
belt
right
and so every time you had a seat belt
there's a little toll in your car and it
goes cling cling 25
25 every time you put on a seat belt
wouldn't you be having have a certain
feeling about it that's more analogous
man
now i know they have to pay people to
like run the testing and all that stuff
but
this amount of money like what's going
on man
you know it's like um and i get the idea
of like testing like like i was on a
pilot i did this abc pilot right and oh
my god i had to get tested three times a
day three not three times a day three
times a week plus on set and i get it
because if someone one of the stars of
the show gets sick they got to shut down
at the time it was like 10 days and it
was like you know you have to shut down
it costs a lot of money so to ensure
that you know we can just keep the
production going they have some strict
procedures and but they paying for it
they're paying for it man
it's not like they were like hey to be
an actor you have to do this no they
they said we want this is our production
we want to take care of this so we want
to make sure it's safe this is what
we're going to do for our procedures so
to work you're going to have to go
through these procedures
this idea of like
like oh you don't care about health and
safety and then like you know some other
idiot hit me up talking about oh
uh you know oh
it's inconvenient you had to take two
tests to
you know you don't care about uh for
health and safety you know it's like you
had to take two tests oh like this is
somebody that obviously don't travel as
much as i do so you don't even
understand that it's not even about just
the inconvenience of it it's just about
like i said just cost out of pocket
right
i love how everybody cares about
everyone's health and safety now
people love talking about this oh health
and safety health and safety you do you
really care about everybody's health and
safety so then what are you doing for
the homeless
huh
like are you if you're preaching about
health and safety then you better be
telling me that you what else are you
doing for the health and safety of your
community huh what are you doing right
what about remember what when we were
kids what about those starving kids in
africa do you care about their health
and safety are you doing something for
that how can you drive by a mcdonald's
and say you care about health and safety
we should be standing in front of
mcdonald's like an abortion clinic you
know with signs picketing when people
come in and we should be being like
you're alive you're a person don't kill
yourself why aren't we doing that since
you care about health and safety but all
of a sudden these virtues signaling
[ __ ] want to
come at everybody about hey health and
safety health and safety nah man
it's i'm it's within my right to be like
yo i don't agree with how we're going
about this health and safety this dog
and pony show for health and safety
i mean it's like you don't travel as
much as i do so you don't know the the
the cost you know what i mean so i don't
even want to hear so shut up you know
what i mean like i'm tired of people
talking about that you know
they want to be all in your business you
know what i mean hey uh you know it's
just because you're like yo i don't
i don't think it's right that we're
forcing people to spend over a hundred
dollars for a test that costs a fraction
of that to do
you know what i mean like don't tell me
like
get on the other side about health and
safety too it's like they want health
and safety and capitalism at the same
time it's like no man i i i care about
people's health and safety and i think
this is [ __ ] okay
that's what i have to say about that
you know what i mean and so it's like
and again me talking about this it don't
mean
i don't think people should be
vaccinated
you know what i mean get vaccinated if
you you know what i mean
it's obviously helping uh you know i
personally my own personal feeling is i
think this [ __ ] would have hit me way
harder if i wasn't vaccinated because
i'm still now still feeling like
lingering effects and i don't know if
it's because of that or if it's because
of like my sinus condition that i've
always had or that counts as a
pre-existing condition that made that
thing worse you know what i mean so i'm
for that
but i'm also for common sense i'm also
for [ __ ] making sense man
so like
keep your virtual signaling ass out of
my business
that's what i have to say about that
stay out of my business okay because you
don't know
you don't know you know what i mean it's
like it's like people only have their
own thoughts and ideas and no matter
what you say they gonna warp your [ __ ]
so they can be like well see
and i'm just like i'm getting tired of
it man i'm just getting tired of it
i'm gonna say this for last time
you could care about health and safety
you could
you could all of that
all of that
and
you could be like yo i don't like how
we're going about
this health and safety procedures i
don't like it and so that's that for
that
okay well hi everybody
um
okay so anyways let me finish so i'm in
canada right all right so now this is my
own personal [ __ ] and about something
else
i pull up i get i get there it's a
nonsense i have to you know i have to
like get an uber or a cab so i get a cab
i put the hotel
i'm thinking the hotel's in the mall
okay
it's not when we pull up this is the
hotel right here the hotel's across the
street from the mall okay
it's freezing
i'm immediately like so i get in the
hotel i'm thinking there ain't nothing
in there they got a microwave in the
lobby that's the amenities i'm on the
first floor of like this is equivalent
to like
it's just it's not the best hotel and i
didn't bust my ass for 20 years to stay
in this hotel and have to walk
every day to do anything like to go to
the club i gotta walk it's like a long
it's not a long walk guys okay and i'm
bougie and i deserve to be bougie i've
been in this business 20 years okay i
you know i've earned some i've earned
some [ __ ] in my opinion
i gotta walk
so i put my bags down
and i didn't even put on a good jacket
and i walked over to the mall
almost tripped three times on this black
ice because there's no real walkway to
go from there to there just [ __ ] snow
on the ground it's wet i was like all
right get to the mall i say i get to the
hotel in the mall you got some rooms oh
yeah check me in please
i checked and they were like oh i see
that's our sister company all right they
even saw my reservation then they were
like oh should we just bill it to the
same people yup build it to the same
people you know
went walked back got my stuff went into
the hotel
because the lady saw how agitated i was
she upgraded me too i had a hot tub in
my room and i was like this is how i
want to be treated by the way
okay so that's where i was with that
so then you know i get a text the
owner's like eric why did you do that
this hotel is 600 more i was like
so
charge me then that's what i said you
think i'm doing this for the money it's
not just for the money my comfort level
is important this is what i don't
understand about some of these clubs out
here they just think like it don't
matter just it don't matter where the
comic stays it don't matter the comics
mood it don't matter like if they're
comfortable it don't matter just get to
the show make people laugh so we can
sell drinks and food
nah man
my mood should be important that's the
time i feel about it i feel like if the
comics in a good mood i could put on a
good show now of course there's a level
of professionalism that's on my side
because believe me i was upset by this i
was upset i was man i was off the rails
i was ready to go home i was telling my
agent i'm ready to get on a plane
tomorrow i'm gonna go to the airport get
the cover test and i'm out of here right
but then i remembered
i got tons of messages from people
who were like eric we bought tickets
can't wait to see you saturday so then
my [ __ ] kicked in where i was like you
know what regardless of the situation
it's my job to put on a good show so i
can [ __ ] about all this stuff i'm
talking about i can feel that i should
be taken care of better that is okay but
no matter what was going on with me
i still got to go on stage and perform
that's how i feel about it what i'm
talking about right now is just
the relationship that clubs and comics
should have
and i feel like this is one of these
things where it's like yo
bend over backwards and and and make
sure that this relationship is good so
we could put on a good show so people
will laugh and have fun and be like oh i
want to come back to that place because
when that one guy was there i had such a
good time i think that's important too
and this just you know and by the way
this is why people
are quitting their jobs and not going
back to work okay
because of how their bosses treat them
why would you want to work at a place
where
all the owner cares about is money they
don't care about your well-being nothing
so when you got an opportunity to be
like yo the government's gonna give me
some money
whatever you sitting there like why
would i want to go back to work
like like it's like almost like you want
to go to the owner of the place and be
like why would i want to work for you
you're you you're terrible
so yeah i'm gonna go take this
government money and uh
um you know what i mean like i totally
get why that is a feeling that people
have it's like yo
what's going on
so i know once that government money
runs out and people got to go back to
work because they got to pay their bills
it's going to be a tough time it's going
to be a tough time and this is exactly
uh what
this is this is similar to that
feeling you know
but
that being said
it all worked out in the end it was good
shows
and they took care of the hotel
okay so it is what it is but i'm just
saying initially
i was upset
you know what i mean and
it's all relative you have your own
life
this is my life so
i'm allowed to to worry about what i
want to worry about you know just like
if bill gates is on uh the tarmac and
his private jet and there's something
going on with the runway and he's
bitching about hey why does my jet have
to go this way yeah the rest of us will
be like dude
you're on a private jet what do you
think nah man it's all relative
everybody got their own experience and
this is my experience and i just feel
like i'll say again when you go
someplace
man comedy clubs out there
take care of the comic man like where
that hotel is is so important it just
really affects your mood is there
restaurants is there things to do well
i'm supposed to just sit in a [ __ ] hotel
all day doing nothing just going to do
your show like i'm some sort of circus
monkey you know what i mean like i'm
just like you know you'll let me out of
my hotel cage go perform now get back in
there you just can't have that sentiment
that feeling you know you got to feel
like you know i'm so i'm
i'm in a good mood then by the time i
get to the show i'm like yeah boom boom
boom so
and again it's also up to the comment
you got to be professional you know what
i mean like i could have went on stage
and just been like whatever but i was
like you know what looking out at those
faces once i get on stage and those
lights hit me i'm like oh man this is
fun and i want to perform and i want to
have a good time so
anyway
it is what it is man
thanks for uh
being here
you know what i mean i'm just saying you
know like so let me let me just look at
the comments
uh
some of these comments man you guys some
of you guys just you just you just argue
for the sake of arguing also some guy
said bill gates analogy don't work and
i'm rich
what the [ __ ] are you talking about all
i'm saying is
rich people complain about rich people
stuff if you're not rich and you're
looking up at them being like why are
you complaining your life is great
that's what i'm saying it's like it's
all relative to everyone everyone has
like you know every whoever has more
than you you look up at them and go you
shouldn't have to complain about
anything and that's just not true it's
all relative okay
anyway
i'm i'm done with this guy um anyways
guys uh that's all i'm that's the bit
bitching whiffin bitchin with riff and
griffin
[Laughter]
let's get to
what's going on this week okay let's get
to what's going on this week first thing
i want to talk about is
guys this fan tastic nfl weekend
wow
i mean some of the best nfl we've seen
these playoffs themselves have been just
some of the best
we've seen in a long time man like so
good you know what i mean
and uh but before we even get in to that
and the nfl let's talk about door dash
doordash our sponsor dash love doordash
you know what i mean like um
ordering food or ordering groceries and
ordering things like that it's such a
great convenience to have especially in
these times or especially like if you're
in a place that has like extreme weather
or whatever it is like that you know
you're paying for you're paying extra
for for a service like this and this
company is a great for that you know
if you ever pull into your driveway
after a trip to the grocery store and
you feel like you forgot something
that's why you have something like
doordash where you can look at your list
and make sure you have everything taken
care of you know what i mean um this
past year taught us to savor every
moment spend less time prepping and
cooking you know and spend time with
your family and your dash can help
you know get what you want to eat right
now right to your door with doordash
along with restaurants you love
you can now get groceries and essential
items delivered with doordash get drinks
snacks and other household items in
under an hour if you crave late night
ice cream rachel and i we always crave
like donuts
rachel always be getting these donuts
from this place this little fancy place
or the donut it'll be like cereal donut
you know what i mean and you
anyway they have that with over 300 000
partners you can support your
neighborhood go-to's or choose from your
favorite national restaurants like
popeye's chipotle cheesecake factory and
all that kind of stuff
excuse me ordering is easy and your
items are left safely outside if that's
what you choose for a limited limited
time our listeners can get 25 off and
zero delivery fees on their first order
of 15 or more when you download the
doordash app and enter code griffin
that's 25 off up to 10 value and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code griffin don't
forget that's code griffin for 25 off
your first order with doordash
subject to changed and terms apply
all right
nfl playoffs
um
[Music]
dude
this this this
okay so first of all
let's just go down the line as to what
happened this past weekend okay so let's
start with titan's bengals
joe burrow is the truth the dude's the
business man he won the national
championship right in college
first year last year he was balling out
right then he got injured now he came
back
and he recovered nicely and he got his
team to the division lead they won that
division
to the player and then how he did it too
like his last four or five games like
400 yards 400 yards he's like he's the
business now we love talking about these
other quarterbacks josh allen catcher
car homes
justin herbert lamar jackson
joe burrow is putting himself in a
position where like he's like yo
don't mess around we might win this
super bowl this year you know what i
mean so kudos to him i think you know
like he's
clearly an mvp
type of player and he's leading that
team and you know the titans man
the
these they're such great young and old
quarterbacks but the great quarterbacks
they gonna run this league for the next
10 15 years so a lot of these teams if
you don't have a quarterback like one of
those guys
i don't know if you could do it in
tennessee the titans they don't have a
quarterback like that unfortunately ryan
tannehill didn't get the job done and
that's what they needed
just as simple as this
if joe burrow was on the titans
and ryan tannehill was on if they
switched quarterbacks the titans would
have blew them out
because they got two phenomenal
receivers
two great running backs and they would
have had the quarterback that can get
the job done it's just as simple as that
so that's how i see it so
looking forward to see what the bangles
can do and then that division is so good
with you know you got lamar jackson
hopefully lamar jackson can get his [ __ ]
together you know actually it's not even
that good anymore because
pittsburgh ben's gone so they need a
quarterback you know baker mayfield and
cleveland who god knows what's going on
with them even though they have a lot of
talent they seem to be one quarterback
away too and then you know lamar jackson
all the injuries that team had can they
bounce back let's see how they do and
then you got joe burrow in cincinnati so
man
the future looks bright for them all
right
all right let's go over to i wanted the
packers to go to the super bowl i
thought aaron rodgers would be what a
great swan song for green bay that would
have been to get to the super bowl win
it but once again he falls short
play a
playoff record of 11 and 10. so it's
like damn you look back on the legacy of
uh aaron rodgers and we're gonna be like
damn is this like he was a great talent
the eye test shows it such a great
football player but damn it just didn't
he just never did it right he just did
it one time
so
that game was something else
i mean jimmy g
man i again i think if you switched
quarterbacks
i think you know
well [ __ ] i think
san francisco really would have won
right
but like what did jimmy g do in that
game it was just it was it was crazy to
think that
they scored six points
san francisco they scored six their
offense only scored six points and then
their defense scored
right
they had a defensive touchdown and two
field goals
green bay's defense did their job
but they just couldn't do and then green
bay
that first drive i was like this is
going to be a blowout because they
couldn't even stop them it was like
pastor adams pastor jones you know what
i mean
touchdown dylan then the next play they
doing the same thing boom boom boom when
that tight end fumbled that ball they
never recovered
so
san francisco just outlasted them did
all the right things
and boom they won the game
so that was a huge upset
wasn't even a great game
i guess if you're into like a defensive
showdown in the snow i guess it was a
great game in terms of that
but if you're a green bay fan you're
just disappointed again so we'll see
what happens
like is aaron rodgers even coming back
and i think he's going to come back
because now all of that stuff that
happened in the off season and all that
vaccination stuff that happened in the
middle of the season
it's all like hey you didn't win and now
all that stuff is gonna be brought up
and it's gonna be held against him and
then him not only winning one super bowl
in 16 years even though he's the most
phenomenal football player like he's so
good right so that was that and then you
got
bucks rams
i'm a rams fan because i'm in la i love
the rams i wanted to you know what i
mean i i want to see this happen
matthew stafford dude he showed up
matthew stanford showed up man
even though they had this lead they let
them come back and it came down to the
wire man on that last drive it was so
dope so you know matthew stafford hits
hits uh cooper cup and when he hit
cooper cup man he was fired up and he
was yelling at his team he was like
let's go get up here he was like so pat
you saw it on his face that i felt like
if that kicker would have missed that
kick
matthew stafford would have beat his ass
on the field i just felt like he was
that passionate about winning this game
i feel like he willed that team and so
you know all the talk about him not
being a winner because he didn't win in
anything in detroit and everybody blamed
detroit for everything you know matthew
stafford's like yo man i got a ball and
now he's finally getting a chance to
prove it so now
they gotta beat the 49ers you understand
i'm saying
me being a homer right now you got to
beat the niners
we going to let jimmy g
go to the super bowl again
that dude got nine lives man if excuse
me if the 49ers go to the super bowl
again with jimmy garoppolo
that'll be insane
good for him though right he's just
going to be looking over that uh replace
that that that rookie like sorry bro
it is what it is man like i'm a winner
regardless of how i do it or how i look
i mean you know what even if you like
jimmy g or not the dude's a winner man
look at his record he just never stays
healthy but he might get to the super
bowl again man it's crazy so kudos to
that game
um you know so
anyways
so the bucks
they couldn't do it like
i thought
there was there was no doubt in my mind
that tom brady was gonna score that
final touchdown right i was like oh here
we go they marched down the field
hit the touchdown 49 seconds left i'm
like oh man it's overtime and then we'll
see what happens in overtime but rams
march down the field cooper cup is a
beast and you know they won the game so
they sent tom brady packing now he's
gonna be 44 45 years old i don't know if
he's going to come back or not because i
don't know if they have enough talent
whoo
i'm sorry about my throat guys it's just
my sinuses have still are still acting
up you know what i mean i didn't take my
allergy medication so you know it is
what it is i'm doing it live
so now let's get to the game
probably
the greatest game
the greatest fourth quarter in nfl
history gotta be they scored 25 points
in like a minute 50.
you know what i mean it was crazy i
wasn't even watching the game fully
because i was streaming on twitch at the
time you know what i mean and oh by the
way that's
eric griffin gaming
[Laughter]
and i had i had it on my phone and i'm
watching it and i'm just like what the
bill scored and i was like oh that's it
game over oh the casey scored what and
then it was like the bill scored casey
scored bill scored casey scored
every time you thought it was done
it was like the bills would score then
you're like oh it's over then kc would
score and then it was like 13 seconds
left 13 seconds left and i was like oh
man bill's got it so i stopped looking
then i look up and i'm like what
it's tied
and then you know they go to overtime
and they can't stop the number one
defense can't stop patrick holmes
now i know there's a lot of talk about
the overtime rules
personally i like the overtime rule now
better than it was it's way better than
it was when you just had to get a field
goal to win
and you know but there really is no fair
way to do it like what don't there's no
fair way to do it because
let's say
at some point
the defense has to step up you see what
i'm saying so let's say the overtime
rule was
you get you keep going until the defense
stops because that would be the only way
so at that point then the defense has to
step up so
so it doesn't matter so i think this is
a perfect overtime rule i think it's
they shouldn't change it because it's
like
patrick the home gets a chance to do it
and then you know then then what you let
josh hand let's say what if the bills
scored let's say they change the
overtime rule the bills come on and
score well then casey gets a chance
again and then they get a chance again
at some point
the other side of the ball has to step
up and make plays
so that's why they changed it to
if you score a field goal
then
next score wins
you know next score wins if it's you
know if you if you get the lead that's
why they changed it because it was you
before it was just ridiculous you just
get to the 40-yard line you win the toss
you're most likely going to win the game
so they changed that but
i don't know
i think it was fair but those two
quarterbacks are just great there really
are and like kudos to josh allen josh
allen might even be better than patrick
mahomes
i know that's crazy to say but that
guy's great
i mean he's big strong fast
dropping dimes i don't know i don't know
who's better i don't know who i would
want i mean he's bigger stronger faster
but patrick mahomes just got that thing
him and joe burrow patching the homes
and joe burrow got that extra thing
there's something crazy about him so i
can't wait for that game
cincinnati
chiefs
this is for
this is what's on the line okay
patrick mahomes is going for greatest of
all time
four afc championships in a row
at the age of 25.
or he's 26. you know
if he wins the super bowl he will have
two super bowls three appearances in his
first
five years
okay in his first five years
then
it's realistic to think
like
if patrick mahomes gets
say
three more championships or even just
two per se if he had three or four
championships on his belt
you'd take him over anyone including tom
brady you know what i mean like he just
needs to get because his talent level
they have won
all this time
because of him
it wasn't some great defense and he was
just being a you know handing the ball
off and just doing like be good on third
down no no
kansas city wins because of him in
brady's first 10 years
they weren't winning because of him
he was just
you know he was he's great i know i'm
taking nothing away from him all i'm
saying is
patrick mahomes he's going for greatest
of all time and this will push him
way towards that a big leaps and bounds
towards that joe burrow joe burrows
playing for i'm the best quarterback in
the league right now y'all keep talking
about herbert and lamar jackson and you
know aaron rodgers and all these people
joe burrows like yo homie this is my
second year in the league
i know i played he played this to his
senior year so he's older you know as a
rookie he was older than most but he's
like i don't care
i'm the man so
that's what he's playing for so
that is such a fantastic game
and of course rams 49ers california runs
this mfa you know look it's california
versus the world so
whoever wins that game i'm rooting for
them in the super bowl like if the 49ers
win the super bowl win this game i want
them to win the super bowl i want jimmy
g to redeem himself
if
stafford and them win the game rams of
course i want them to win the super bowl
and just for stafford too there's so
many great stories
uh
greatest playoffs ever man
greatest playoffs in my life i i haven't
seen a playoff better than this
so anyways
that is the playoff
history that's the playoff portion of
griffin with griffin
damn for some reason as soon as i got
here to this my cough and my sinuses
started acting up even more i think
there's something in my office i gotta
vacuum the rug i gotta clean the desk
something's causing i feel like i'm
allergic to something in here right now
all right guys let's get to
i want to get to this show
as we see it
as we see it stars su and pian
um
wait wait let me go back to this
suzanne pian albert rutek's key i'm not
sure his name is right and my friend
rick glassman
where he's over here oh and let me show
the girl sorry
it's the nature of the green screen that
you can't see but there she is right
there
all right guys
this show is about three roommates on
the autism spectrum
finding a way to live together
and strive for similar things in life
man
this really is
this really is a it's a great show you
know
and
people are doing
such a fantastic job
in the show
and the show just is
you know this it's all it's actually
it's not a fun show i'll tell you that
you got to be prepared for it you know
because and this is like a thing that's
going on in hollywood right now of like
really trying to strive towards more
realism not everything has to be like
you know popcorn fun
this ain't a popcorn fun show this is a
show that really makes you
look at the world and realize that there
are people out there
that live different from you there's
people out there that
they're struggling with their own
personal things and they're trying to
live in a world
and
in a way that we think is normal but
it's not normal for them
it's especially difficult
if i'm being honest
it's hard for me to watch this show
because i'm close friends with rick and
i personally know
the struggles that rick goes through so
you guys just see podcasts and you see
all that stuff but there's an other side
there's there's the everyday life
that he has to live and it's not always
easy for him
so
see him again emotional cause it's my
friend i love him
so i shout out to him
because you know
this is like a great project to show
how people
struggle
and i feel proud
you know because of
you know what he's doing
in his own life and to see him you know
do this
and succeed is like a really
great anyways
you know watch the show you know what i
mean
it's on amazon and it's called as we see
it you know and
i want to show you something i hope this
works
because like
rachel
so we're watching it together and
rachel's just
she's just a crybaby man
[Laughter]
like and she's really
like this show really
this show really moves her you know what
i mean
so
so i like
wait let me do it like this
so i like caught her
i i i don't know if that i don't know
this is going to work or not but let's
see if it works you know
oh it doesn't work damn it this this
thing never works properly videos gonna
show way if you go to my instagram you
go to my instagram you can see rachel i
taped her crying
watching the show and she was like this
is so good you know
you know and i sent it to rick you know
um
so anyways
fantastic show so i do highly recommend
you watch as we see it i don't want to
spoil it for you but i mean there's just
a lot of like really like uncle it's
very uncomfortable you know there's a
lot of uncomfortable moments and you
really are gonna you know you're gonna
enjoy it and you know just look at it
with an open mind open heart because
like i say there are people out there
who are struggling with different
different lifestyles different things
going on in their life
and it's not the same as you and that
you know to to some of us you know
people who are not on that spectrum you
know
simple things become very difficult for
them
whereas like we're worried about like
for me i'm bitching about
some [ __ ] hotel i'm in and
someone else might be like you know they
can't even walk because there's noise
you know
i remember i was out with rick we were
we we had
we were just hanging out after his
podcast and then we're in the parking
lot of this thing and we're having to
come trying to have a conversation and
our car alarm went off
and i could see
rick was just trying to like stay
focused on our conversation but he just
couldn't do it you know and he was like
i gotta go
and i was like oh totally get it
it's like you know what i mean like
something that was easy for me yeah it
was annoying but i could have kept going
so you know what i mean like it's just
like
this show really
shows that
and it's probably the most realistic
representation of people being on the
spectrum
other than a show that
on the spectrum
you know what i mean so once again
super proud of rick
want to put that out there
for him
and
super
endorsement of the show it gets
five woo-woo's
somebody in the chat said car alarm bro
don't even get me
started you still got a car alarm and
you have a page or two you know what i
mean anyways
so that's my review of as we see it
all right let's go on to the next
um okay
here we go one man show
ozarks
season four is back
man
i'm gonna wait a couple weeks
so people can finish
because then i'm gonna spoil it
i'm not gonna do it today
because ozarks just came out
but my goodness
this show this season
is so good
so you don't know what ozarks was about
he never watched it
it's about jason bateman
he's a money launderer
for a mexican cartel
and
he has to
he moves to he and he's based in chicago
so he moves to the ozarks some major
stuff happens
where you know his wife is cheating on
him
you know she doesn't really know about i
think she knew i forgot from season one
if she knew about the mother laundering
or not and they got two kids and they
have to move their family
to the ozarks to launder money for the
cartel and it's just a story about
you know how he has to maneuver through
his family his relationship with his
wife and also
deal with
the local mob
the local drug dealers
and
get out from underneath this mexican
cartel
and it's just
fabulous the relationship with the
family is fabulous
the the acting job is fabulous it's like
it's really good and this season is so
good like i just saw the final episode
of part one because it's two parts so
part one of season four how it ended i
was like
ah
i can't believe that they did that so i
don't wanna spoil it because you know me
i like to spoil stuff
but um
no jason bateman is not a drug smuggler
i didn't nobody said that are you
listening idiot
too many idiots in the chat man i mean
i'm telling you it's just idiots galore
jason bateman is a money he's a money
guy he's like a he's a super smart
business savant when it comes to like
hiding money
and and taking care of like money
laundering and you know numbered
accounts and and he's trying to wash the
drug money and make it legal so it's
it's all about and you know and so he's
needed and it's just like it's a mob
story it really is you know it's a mob
story so it's like gangster stuff along
with family
ma in the ozarks so it's uh it's really
good
i i highly recommend it
so
i give ozarks
a super whiffer griffin
five woo-woos
let me get it ready
[Music]
just pay attention idiot okay how about
that how about just pay attention in the
chat
i know people listening that people
listening later are probably hearing
this and they're like what do i wonder
what's going on that's just you know you
gotta listen live okay so i had to go
out of town i had to leave on wednesday
i know i said i was gonna do it last
week but i am gonna do it this week so i
am gonna have a bonus episode this week
i'm gonna go live but then to watch it
you gotta be a youtube member or you got
to go to my patreon which is eric
griffin
so
i'm going to do that this week so
um
and if you have some ideas if the shows
or whatever
you know i still i might go into details
about a thing i've already done before
and still talk about stuff but you know
i like doing this i actually like going
live i like just well right off the cuff
you know so
you know
doing it like this so it's all good but
once again ozarks pretty good
pretty good show
i do reckon i do recommend it so if you
haven't
watched it i do suggest you start it up
you know what i mean like startup ghost
season one it's totally worth the watch
i actually wish i hadn't have like
watched it all
like because it'd be great to have to
have four seasons ready to go right now
because that you know i like binging but
i also like that feeling of having to
wait too
that anticipation makes you feel good so
but anyways guys um
i think that's all i got this week you
know in recap
nfl playoffs
absolutely fabulous
so make sure you guys check that out
you know it's gonna be so good
um
you know
nfl playoffs i can't wait i'm gonna talk
about it again next week i'm just gonna
talk about it till this done all the way
up to the super bowl so that was really
great
as we see it with my buddy rick glassman
i highly recommend you watch that show
it's a really good show
ozark season four
and also guys
[Applause]
just because
people have feelings about
you know having to spend money on tests
it don't mean they don't care about
health and safety okay
like
keep your virtue signaling to yourself
because you sound like an idiot okay
[Music]
other than that i want you guys to be
safe
have a great week
[Music]
i'm gonna be in the la area if you're in
la all week no no shows for me this
weekend and then i'm going to missouri
in
february uh so check the website for
that
also check me out on eric griffin gaming
daily
probably gonna be on after this
that's it
love y'all see you next week
[Music]
[Music]